[Musique]
sensation sensation le mag bonjour à
tous bienvenue sur sensation en
association avec TV 78 parcourir 5800 km
à vélo pour sensibiliser à la leucémie
et au don de moelle c'est le défi que
s'est lancé Bertrand Paulet bonjour
bonjour alors vous êtes accompagnés
bonjour également ensemble vous
souhaitez sensibiliser à la leucémie à
travers ce défi envahir venir dans
quelques instants mais aussi à travers
plusieurs événements alors euro vero
c'est une association qui a vu le jour
pour rendre également hommage à
Véronique alors pourquoi il vous a
semblé essentiel de fonder cette
association
Rover eau donc pour vous remettre dans
le contexte Véronique était la femme de
Bertrand ici à présent et c'était ma
meilleure amie depuis 23 ans et à l'âge
de 37 ans elle venait tomber enceinte et
elle a découvert malheureusement qu'elle
avait une leucémie c'est-à-dire un
cancer du sein
et donc suite à ça elle a eu un combat
de cinq années pour pour lutter elle a
eu deux grèves de moelle osseuse et
malheureusement elle est décédée en ce
début d'année et nous on a été
accompagnant mais en été passif dans
cette va dans cette maladie et
aujourd'hui on veut devenir acteur et on
veut sensibiliser à la fois au don de
moelle osseuse et récolter des fonds
pour lutter contre la leucémie c'est
pour ça qu'on a fondé l'association euro
un très bel hommage finalement à travers
donc une association et un défi on parle
beaucoup du don de sang un peu moins du
don de plasma et peu du don de de moelle
osseuse vous souhaitez justement à
travers le combat de Véronique
sensibiliser au don de moelle que permet
justement le don de moelle osseuse pour
les personnes atteintes de d'une
leucémie je vais continuer encore c'est
vrai que moi personnellement je pense
que la plupart des gens ne connaissent
pas ou ne savent pas exactement ce que
c'est que que la moelle osseuse c'est un
organe vital qui se trouve dans nos eaux
et c'est c'est là où se produisent en
fait toutes les cellules sanguines c'est
à dire les globules rouges qui diffusent
l'oxygène les globules blancs qui
servent à lutter contre les infections
et les plaquettes qui servent à la
coagulation et à la cicatrisation donc
c'est vraiment un organe vital et les
maladies du sang comme les leucémies
c'est un dysfonctionnement en fait de
cette moelle osseuse et le seul moyen
d'espérer pouvoir en guérir c'est
d'avoir une greffe de moelle osseuse
donc c'est voilà ne pas confondre avec
la moelle épinière c'est vraiment deux
choses très différentes et
et je voulais dire
vous allez justement mettre plusieurs
actions aussi en place tels que des
rencontres ou des concerts alors quels
sont les objectifs justement de ces
rencontres c'est de sensibiliser
vraiment notamment les jeunes parce que
pour pouvoir être d'honneur il faut
avoir moins de 35 ans donc c'est
vraiment quelque chose sur lequel on
veut on veut jouer en allant rencontrer
Bertrand pendant son circuit et puis
même voilà autour de toute la
communication qu'on va pouvoir faire
c'est de sensibiliser les jeunes que ce
soit voilà les tous les personnes qu'on
rencontre lors de concert ou de
manifestations de rendre compte qu'on
peut faire donc ça c'est d'une part
cette sensibilisation d'autre part
d'aller rencontrer aussi les chercheurs
et de mettre en lumière tout leur
travail parce qu'on connaît très peu
leur travail et ils travaillent main
dans la main avec avec des organismes de
santé ou les hôpitaux
et
également de collecter des informations
de faire un espèce de reportage pendant
ce voyage sur sur la recherche de façon
générale et puis collecter des fonds
aussi pour pour la recherche contre la
leucémie et rappeler aussi et surtout
que la leucémie touche de toute façon
tous les âges il n'y a pas d'âge
justement pour être atteint d'une
leucémie alors qu'est-ce que les
échanges justement avec des
professionnels peuvent apporter aux
familles aux familles des malades alors
ça va apporter un peu d'espoir après on
peut pas apporter beaucoup de choses en
plus mais c'est voilà nous aujourd'hui
on peut être acteur quand on est patient
quand on est accompagnant on est souvent
seul et on peut pas forcément donner de
l'énergie là-dedans donc c'est c'est
pour apporter quelques éléments de
réponse et moi j'ai une anecdote à ce
sujet il y a un mois j'ai rencontré un
chercheur sur la leucémie au
commissariat de l'énergie atomique
je savais que le CEVA travaillait avec
l'hôpital Mignot où était hospitalisé
Véronique et voilà lorsque j'ai commencé
à présenter un peu le profil de la
maladie qu'elle avait qui était une
maladie assez rare il a marqué un blanc
et je pense qu'il s'est rendu compte en
fait que en face de lui il avait le mari
d'un tube à essai parce que voilà cette
personne là personnalisée en fait les
traitements qui étaient mis au point
pour les malades de cet hôpital
et et moi forcément j'ai été touché
aussi
je me suis rendu compte que on mettait
pas suffisamment en avant en fait auprès
des familles des malades ou même des
malades que derrière il y avait toute
une équipe c'était pas uniquement des
des médecins il y a vraiment une équipe
gigantesque et ses chercheurs ont fait
on mérite aussi on mérite de il mérite
d'être mis en valeur et je pense
qu'effectivement ça donne un peu
d'espoir effectivement d'ailleurs
justement cette hommage et cette
valorisation de de des métiers et donc
l'hommage à donc à la fois à Véronique
mais également à tous les malades
finalement de leucémie le gros défi de
cette année c'est vous Bertrand qui
allait le faire vous souhaitez parcourir
5800 km à vélo dans toute l'Europe alors
quel est le parcours justement organisé
lors de cette aventure alors le parcours
et c'est de là que vient le nom revero
c'est de suivre le la vélo route des
pèlerins qui s'appelle aussi euro vélo 3
voilà donc c'est un ensemble de tronçons
de pèlerinage historique c'est un
itinéraire qui est très très bien balisé
qui part de Trondheim en Norvège qui
traverse 7 pays donc la Norvège la Suède
le Danemark l'Allemagne la Belgique la
France et enfin l'Espagne pour arriver à
Saint-Jacques de Compostelle et là
pourquoi justement traverser les
l'Espagne et ce qu'il va y avoir
également encore une fois des échanges
avec des professionnels ou avec des
citoyens aussi on le souhaite puisque le
but aussi de traverser ces différents
pays c'est que voilà ce sont des pays
qui sont très très bien sensibilisés
aujourd'hui au don de moelle osseuse et
c'est celle d'aller faire une espèce de
de reportage documentaire pour voir
quelles sont les bonnes pratiques voir
un peu quel est le niveau de
sensibilisation en fait des populations
locales et voilà donc ça a vraiment un
intérêt pour autant
même si voilà les associations qui
militent ne sont pas les mêmes que
celles qui sont en France il y a aussi
un besoin de constant de de donneurs
dans ces pays-là donc on travaille
actuellement également avec des kms qui
est l'équivalent de l'Agence de
biomédecine en France voilà pour
promouvoir aussi chez eux le don de
moelle osseuse et ce défi il sert
également à récolter des dons pour la
recherche et la sensibilisation du don
de moelle osseuse à quoi servira
l'argent l'argent récolté ce que vous
êtes soutenu justement par plusieurs
associations ou une institution alors
aujourd'hui on travaille main dans la
main avec l'association Laurette Fugain
qui est un peu la l'association de tête
de pont dans la lutte contre la leucémie
en France on les a rencontrés se sont
vraiment des des gens très très sérieux
donc voilà on va vraiment travailler en
tandem avec eux et lors du périple
l'intégralité des des fonds qui seront
collectés seront directement reversés à
le l'association leur être Fugain qui a
trois missions la première mission est
d'accompagner les familles des enfants
qui sont de leucémie la seconde mission
c'est une mission de sensibilisation
comme la nôtre donc on se comprend très
bien avec nous et la troisième mission
c'est de financer les chercheurs voilà
alors effectivement aujourd'hui il
garantissent 500.000 euros par an
minimum à l'ensemble des chercheurs et
c'est souvent leur seule source de
financement et malgré tout enfin vous
êtes passionné de vélo mais 5800 km
n'est pas rien alors comment vous êtes
préparé justement enfin comment vous
préparez à ce périple alors oui c'est un
défi en soi puisque lors de
l'accompagnement de Véronique j'ai pas
pris soin de moi donc j'ai pris 20 kilos
en 5 ans donc rien que de me remettre en
forme c'est déjà un défi heureusement on
a la chance d'avoir dans les amis de
Véronique et du coup dans l'association
un coach sportif professionnel qui
rigole pas du tout avec l'entraînement
donc il me fait me lever très tôt le
matin pour pédaler enfin bon j'essaie
d'être sérieux et depuis peu on est
également une naturopathe voilà qui qui
m'aide à la remise en forme
et je pense que ça va me faire du bien
et cette volonté dommage et de
sensibilisation de toute façon vous
donnera je pense énormément de
énormément de force comment est-ce qu'on
pourra suivre votre votre aventure
est-ce qu'il existe des réseaux sociaux
justement pour suivre votre parcours
alors aujourd'hui on a un site internet
eurover.org sur lequel j'écrirai un blog
donc on pourra bien entendu aller lire
les
l'aventure sur le blog mais ces messages
seront aussi relayés sur nos pages
Facebook et Instagram que l'on peut
trouver et suivre directement depuis
notre site internet donc par rapport au
site internet on pourra de toute façon
tout retrouver et il y aura notamment le
blog et pour conclure finalement cette
émission je vais faire que reprendre vos
mots faire un don c'est sauver une vie
merci beaucoup Bertrand Paulet et
Emmanuel Mercier d'avoir été avec nous
sur sensation donc Emmanuel Mercier je
rappelle que vous êtes présidente de
l'association euro et Bertrand vous êtes
le cyclo du coup qui va parcourir les
5800 km pour plus d'informations on peut
se rendre vous l'avez dit mais je le
rappelle euro.org c'est le site le site
internet et pour voir ou réécouter cette
émission rendez-vous sur notre site et
notre application radio sensation